seck la chaussure française est en crise
il faut le savoir en europe
ce ne sont que les fabricants très
spécialisés qui peuvent survivre et même
progresser cela spectaculairement
c'est le cas des fameuses doc martin
s'il y a trente ans ces godillots ont
été inventés par un médecin le docteur
martins fabriqué aujourd'hui en
angleterre
elles se vendent par dizaines de
millions d'exemplaires par an le dalaï
lama madonna et jean paul ii ont sondé
adepte notre enquête de ce soir mené par
nicolas winckler et vient cas est
intitulé une grosse pointure
ils en avaient fait leur emblème on les
a aperçus sur le chemin de la sagesse
les sur ceux de la haine avec les
skinheads
on les a vus sur les planches avec
madonna
le vatican aussi à c'est très sain de
paix en somme avec les actes martins
tout l'été du monde se donne enfin la
main vous êtes à 200 km au nord de
l'europe
plus de 10 millions de paires sont
sortis de ses chaînes de fabrication
l'an dernier ce qui fait du groupe
grieg l'heureux détenteur du brevet le
premier fabricant européen de chaussures
la botte secrète
c'est à coussin d'air inventé par le
docteur martin qu un médecin qui voulait
en faire une chaussure orthopédique
la première est sorti 10 leur 1960 et 37
ans plus tard la famille griggs d'or
grâce à sa puce inverse sur un vrai
coussin d'air
ring demain je pense que docteur martin
aussi bien à l'étranger qu'ici même en
angleterre est connu essentiellement
pour son côté authentiquement ma
conviction c'est comme un petit morceau
de notre culture pop et je crois que le
consommateur qui achète notre produit
achète un petit morceau de 7 ce devait
être au départ des chaussures pour les
oubliés ou les agriculteurs mais à ceux
qui prétendaient qu'elle ne serait
jamais autre chose que de bons gros
godillots ses chaussures ont fait ce
qu'il convient d'appeler formidable pied
de nez 4000 mètres carrés akhavan garden
au coeur de londres
un magasin à la gloire de la marque et
tout va bien merci pour eux les affaires
tournent note martin s'exporte plus que
bien puisque 70% des chaussures partent
à l'export un phénomène de mode unique
en son genre
il dure depuis maintenant plus de trente
ans on a depuis créé une infinité de
modèles la clientèle de ce magasin c'est
90 % de touristes bret
il ya ceux qui aime traîner leurs
baskets musées et les autres ceux qui
préfèrent le shopping difficile
jeter mes voitures la région dont hugo à
revenir
et comme souvenir des cellules es jeune
hakim faire des vagues
mais on a acheté par jacqueline d'être
prêt pour le voyage
alors on quitte londres pour bordeaux
c'est ici en effet qui est installé
l'importateur français les consommateurs
de l'hexagone lui aussi est aussi ont
adhéré la société connaît une croissance
exponentielle un chiffre d'affaires ces
vidéos de façon régulière d'année en
année aux dernières nouvelles c'est à
dire l'an dernier 800 mille paires ont
trouvé pieds leurs chaussures
l'une des forces de la marque c'est sa
présence dans plus de 1400 points de
vente
mais hélas quand tout va bien il y à
aussi la rançon du succès avec martins
n'a jamais cessé de plaire mais n'a
jamais cessé aussi d'être copié et
recopié sur son voisin c'est fabu sévit
la vie la vie la ville nous avons rennes
perd deux docteurs therman qui vient
d'espagne je pense qui ressemble pas mal
à une paire de doc vous avez de
fabrication italienne qui sont assez
proches également donc les
caractéristiques essentielles de nos
produits sont repris donc surpiqûres
jaunes très points noirs se mêlent strié
translucide
les fun que les skinheads des cadres et
les ouvriers le parquet les dalaï lama
si tous les pieds du monde ce sont ainsi
deux gamins c'est que dieu et le diable
porte peut-être la même paire de
souliers
c'est